a person wanted to know why is everyone
getting shingles nowadays i mean it
seems like everyone's getting shingles
now that's a bit of an exaggeration but
there definitely is an increase in the
amount of people getting shingles now
what is shingles
it's a virus it's called herpes zoster
and it's a virus that remains dormant
for many many years
and then it can come out and create all
sorts of pain and misery
especially on the surface of the skin
that follows
nerves around your rib cage it can come
up through your back through the front
in fact it can become so painful
certain people become suicidal so it's a
really big deal
normally one and a half to 2.5 people
out of a thousand will get shingles okay
but between 2000 and 2007
three of a thousand people are getting
it so it's definitely
going up and there's even a higher
incidence of people getting shingles
in certain areas of the country which
i'm going to talk about
so you have a situation where this virus
is in a dormant stage and it's just
waiting there
it's not doing anything it's waiting for
the right environment so that it can
come out
and create a lot of discomfort for you
has to do with
how healthy your immune system is if
there's anything
suppressing your immune system that's
when it comes out
so again the topic of viruses come down
to your
own immune system is it healthy is it
weak
it's an area that not many people
emphasize but it's not until your immune
system gets weakened or suppressed
that this virus then comes out and
creates the problem so let's talk about
what can trigger
this virus coming out of remission
number one drugs
for cancer drugs for asthma
prednisone drugs for autoimmune diseases
all will suppress your immune system
number three
radiation has a strong effect of
bringing this virus out of remission
so how are you exposed to radiation well
you can get an x-ray
or what about sun why is it that the
majority of
outbreaks of shingles occur during the
summer months
is because of the sun so more sun
more radiation more outbreaks
stress can be a big factor in whether
this virus comes out of remission
a poor diet lack of nutrients lack of
sleep
and number seven and this is why i'm
doing this video this is an extra thing
that i didn't know before
i found some interesting research on it
so i wanted to share it with you
pesticides and insecticides yes those
have a direct effect on weakening
your immune system and unfortunately
guess what's been going
up in recent years more exposure
to pesticides and insecticides so we're
just going to add another thing to the
list to help you
keep these pesticides out of your body
so number one this is what i'm going to
recommend if you have shingles
do fasting very very important it's
going to help you number two
vitamin d probably about between 40 and
50 000 iu's
because you need a very strong natural
thing that acts like cortisol
to actually put this thing back in
remission but
not sun even though the sun helps you
activate vitamin d
i'm going to recommend getting the
vitamin d directly from a supplement
and not getting the radiation because
vitamin d will help but we don't need
the radiation in this situation
number three vitamin c in this case i
would take higher amounts like a
thousand milligrams three times a day
number four zinc i probably take
anywhere between
50 to 100 milligrams of zinc number five
l-lysine number six melatonin
and number seven to pull out these
pesticides
i would start consuming more cruciferous
vegetables
and the one i would eat more of would be
radishes okay
radishes have a very potent effect at
creating the
detox that you need to pull out these
pesticides
and insecticides and of course start
eating organic as well because that's
going to be
vitally important all right thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
video
hey before you go if you're benefiting
from
any of my content i would love
to hear about your success story please
share it
in the link down below